et bien bonjour je suis aujourd'hui avec
maxence carlito et le péage les amis
aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu auquel
on joue et qu'on était tout petit qui
s'appelle cache cache on va faire ça en
trois manches
à chacune de ses trois manches les deux
équipes iront se cacher à trouver
européenne et vidéos que vous avez tous
tant que voulait pour allez vous cacher
quand vous êtes caché vous nous appelez
vous nous dites je suis caché à partir
de là à l'aide de nos au nord 9 lite qui
sponsorise cette vidéo merci merci je
vais proposer qu'on pourra savoir vous
êtes sur google maps car on a partagé
nos positions on sait où vous êtes nous
deux ou vous rejoins en véhicule
motorisé
une fois qu'on arrive sur place on a
quinze minutes pour vous trouver si on
vous trouve on gagne un point car on
vous a trouvé dans le temps imparti on
va alors se cacher c'est ensuite à vous
de nous chercher je vous laisse deviner
qui d'entre les binômes sera le meilleur
je suis avec mc saint raphaël est avec
les rotules avec l'étoile montante de
youtube si vous gagnez vous voulez qu'on
fasse quoi je veux qu'ils impriment
photos - soit gentil qu'il apporte moi
c'est bien moi j'ai avec lucas pour toi
un petit chapeau de fête donc ça passe
juste au début
non non non toute la vidéo allons leur
ralliement à les honneurs aux invités ça
commence à temps avant la tempête le
calme mairie de sarcelles ligne 14
je te dise un truc ça se trouve ils vont
se cacher dans le bâtiment ici c'est le
seul bâtiment
donc vouloir dire nous nous avons les
choisit de moi-même et de qualité sauf
qu'en fait on va les placer quelque part
dans la wave justement très près de là
aujourd'hui qu'un énoncé par contre
vraiment caché dans un container et le
treuil électrique on va semer le doute
à l'aide de ce faux sosie haye bougies
bull ça y est ça y est ça et ça y est je
tiens à vous dire que lucas m'a appelé
en disant [ __ ] mais vous n'êtes pas
parti
le point il bouge pas sur la map on
s'attendait ce qui touche si longtemps
mais un vélo musique qui me plaît
trahison bike les bâtards s'enregistrer
à côté et autres intrigues se remet
juste à côté
donc on va les appeler là pour leur dire
qu'on est caché personne ne regarde ça
les gars personnes regardez là bas vous
faites votre vie ça pourrait être un
bâtiment donc qu'est-ce qui adore ses
soins en a dans les égouts souffert
genre personnes nous appellent nous
appellent alors vous nous entendez oui
on est d'accord que le point n'a pas
bougé non ok il ya clairement en tout
cas moi je parle ensemble écouter à
temps mais comment voient ils nous
embêtent ils ont dit un accord dont n'a
pas bougé bon ben alors c'est vrai
habito est sincère l'artha côté
à chaque fois on est votée
non mais
et à leurs cadres heures qui sont là les
leur cadre art qui les suit vas-y
chorale et max banon faire courir un peu
parce qu'on a pris trop de temps merci
d'être là car les taux c'est cool merci
je reste dans ma vie d'anne sont bien
sûr ouais franchement je pense je suis
presque sûr que ça capte trop mal donc
on n'a pas le droit d'aller dans des
bâtiments ok on n'a pas retrouvé son jeu
c'est max vois la pudeur cadreur parce
qu'ils ont des go pro et doivent être
dans un endroit ils sont cachés vénère
et pas filmer car un groupe pro vous
savez un parador je deviens parano de
ouf
mais ça se trouve ils sont juste dehors
ils nous voient de 800 c'est sûr oui
c'est sur une voie de là où ils sont
chic chic chic ou un truc comme ça on
tente tu veut l'ouvrir ça je crois c'est
dans
oui à l'eau alors les garçons on ne
trouve pas les gars vous avez pris le
seul bâtiment autorisez vous êtes trop
malin le temps est écoulé nous avons
gagné on vous propose de sortir et
bâtiments à temps avance a dit vous êtes
vraiment les meilleurs vraiment meilleur
que nous bougez pas bougé par la mecque
ses défauts truc ses défauts et je les
aime ça tu viens tous les jours car je
crois que je me suis dit mais c'est une
nouvelle arche à l'aîné a la gallega
bravo pour ce point on vous a pas trouvé
vous avez gagné un point vous allez vous
changer parce que c'est pas du tout
votre style habituel et on va à nou allé
se cacher pendant ce temps là est
peut-être que d'autres items max ça nous
manquait
[Musique]
ces partis bien
nous arriver sur une première cachette
qui n'est pas des moindres puisqu'on va
se planquer sous l'eau sous une marque
avec un tuba on sera invisible le seul
moyen qui nous battre c'est qu'il soit
de l'autre côté de la rive et qui voit
le tube a dépassé parce que 10,6
rappelant qu'il est allé bas et donc ils
ne verront pas ok clairement ils sont
équipés de l'eau on y va un peu comme si
c'était la chasse au trésor au sylvari
jointe yeux ok allez c'est parti on y va
mais qui ralentit plus je suis assez bas
il faut les plongeurs de tomates ou des
jo à la limite du temps là il s'est
passé un truc là
[Musique]
et là c'est pas un changement de
fringues seul parce que il prend
beaucoup trop de temps pour mettre un
t-shirt se déguise un maquillage et à
max elle accroche beaucoup ça lui a
racheté la route la muette à neuilly
s'il vous plaît on arrive petit canard
ou le s'appelle on est bien se cacher
tout de suite
les magic sam ici tournée va puis j'ai
vraiment hâte de les voir déguisé en
haut à gauche on a quinze minutes néo
kamit 15 minutes
regarde le lac lac trouve-moi claque la
balle avec l'état mais qu'est-ce que
s'ils sont juste sur une barque c'est
nul
bah non mais ils sont parmi tout ce
temps pour semer dans une barre c'est
génial même si ça n'a pas de sens aussi
s'interroger sur la zone soit vous êtes
maxence et squeeze on s'éloigne de la
crise était mec en a plus beaucoup à
l'équipe
j'essaie déjà le tour qui tout au boulot
apparemment c'est par là cherchant les
un pilote dans l'avion là bas je suis
imbattable à s'alarmer ils sont
peut-être dans l'eau [ __ ] mais que
j'ai envie d'aller là bas
georges bien réfléchi au fait qu'ils ont
bien préparé ok je vais vers des bateaux
il ya des bateaux des gens là dedans et
nous les mecs ils sont cachés en dessous
la barre
laconique magie mais je suis désolé de
dire cette phrase mais pas si vite aller
au bout c'est casse gueule c'est bien la
[ __ ] si ce n'est pas légal
c'est pourquoi la solution pana
c'est aller bien vite j'ai montré chez
d'autres idées c'est noté c'est bon j'ai
eu un flash mc fois c'est évident qu'ils
sont dans l'eau c'est halak mais jimmy
choo
je suis désolé il décide de louer mais
c'était dans nos ânes on avait raison on
a juste été nuls on a manqué de réalisme
dans la surface regarde qu'omega des
rayons de riom c'est génial c'est qu'à
chaque fois on est vraiment à ça on est
en stress ont été payés on a approché
des barques je suis espagnol corse des
algériens du coup j'ai beaucoup de ses
membres
là vraiment je ne sais pas attendre à
fond ne perd pas là c'était un partout
appartenant qui gardent leur place est à
nous cacher on ira tout de suite comme
ça vous allez aux changements vous avez
vous cachez pas plus qu'alexandre merci
nous sommes à l'église de pompidou j'ai
pas le nom exactement on va se mettre
sur le balcon là où déguisé en
gargouille exactement
pas que les gens nous crise sinon c'est
mort peut pas s'installer est maintenant
question devant les infos qu'ils sont et
on l'espère d'offres exclusives à les
croiser déstabiliser bientôt nous sommes
cachés
ok ok les gars on n'est pas loin on
arrive on arrive bon courage les gars
sont au revoir qui sont à côté de
l'église st même l'amour fou cette
sensation la chance c'est qu'il ya plein
de touristes donc regarder trop satria
les touristes qui vont regarder dans la
direction et s'annonce pas que tu bouges
pas d'accord il faut vraiment tous les
gens de la place ont regardé sauf à
cheval à lausanne vers l'as hatten aucun
va là où il y avait écrit dina debbas
cissé droite gauche
j'étais là surtout un couple a alors est
ce qu a pas une entrée d'un tunnel où
couraient ces vases et jaka claque si un
taux de verser qu'un tunnel entre
d'enchaînements wismond sa patience et
sa souveraineté sur max martin luther
qui flotte sur place ça c'est bon ça
c'est mauvais et les bons se trouve mais
qui sont parmi les gens qui nous
prennent des photos
[Musique]
rien trouvé c'est ce qui achèvera moyens
groupe au milieu aussi il ya des gens
qu'on connaît dans groupe mais oui ça
fait bizarre
sénèque c'est vraiment un truc avec eux
il ya les casinos à des gens qui font
coucou
et c'est ça le bassin parisien
bon on va plus là bas oh la la c'est
bien ce qui me regarde et j'ai voulu
regarder ya rire de quoi y'a juste une
place avec des gens et on est paumé quoi
attention et ruby qui revient et qui
revient ça se trouve il avait un gros
make up on les reconnaît pas genre a
fait la dèche dernière soir dernière
ligne à rien et une place on voit tous
n'y a pas de plan que j'aime pas qu'on
me l'ont fait
j'ai aucune idée mais que j'arrive pas
j'ai aucune idée
bon c'est bon là on ya tellement de rien
hall et bata impossible à les battre et
la casse on s'en fout des parents
derrière nous vois les mecs on arrivé
sur place il y aurait une fontaine ya un
million de jeunes qui nous prennent en
photo et je me dis c'est sûr thaler
group est en mettant des clones de paix
font pareil sont déguisés un enfant et
du coup je regardais très très mal tous
les enfants regardaient comme ça et
c'est très joli but puisque les gens
venant foot ou mais il nous fait des
bisous ouais bon c'est un spectacle
pitoyable ou y arriver en gare goût il
dit d'ailleurs on était là avec nos
grandes oies de bergen ça vous fait un
point allez on va se cacher le chao bon
on se dirige actuellement vers la
deuxième cache at il faut savoir c'est
que entre les prises on adore mettre
l'équipe adverse sur de fausses pistes
et là on leur a dit que c'est le cash
est là elle est extrêmement dur alors
qu'en fait c'est la plus in detroit est
évident qu'on va faire ce que j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire dans un cache
cache se fondent dans la masse c'est
parti
c'est grillé mais qu on va être
brillamment réagi ce matin
en fait il aurait fallu tous les
cagoules et le mannequin max on va se
faire griller en une minute le plan de
base a échoué on voulait en place les
mannequins mais ça marche pas c'est trop
grillé horrible donc on va juste se
cacher dans ces petits rayons et ce qui
est bien c'est qu'on a mis 30 minutes à
trouver ça ils vont penser qu'on va set
up un truc hyper compliqué et on alors
pas du tout on est vraiment vivre sa vie
non je sais pour halo attends attends à
l'eau je suis caché et que sur les
scenarii aura rien on va vous débusquer
à tout ils étaient chargés d'aller au
niveau hockey
son emploi ils sont ici au père par
rapport aux magasins autour tu choisis
châtelet pour un truc précis tu vois ce
que m [ __ ] des mannequins ou des
balles car ils sont allons voir c'est
sûr je suis embêté sur bonjour comment
allez vous on peut rentrer dans le
magasin
absolument on arrive peut-être c'est pas
moi c'est toi je crois pas mais c'était
une très bonne et des intestins mais
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça
on reconnaît dans le magasin par société
aussi que dante non mais oui c'est par
le biais d'un ascenseur hors service et
rigole la prod rigole vraiment sait
qu'on est rentré nul ça rend aux savants
ou j'aime pas perdre de temps ils sont
clairement déguisés ou quoi sous ce nom
ne dit pas que c'est même qu'un méchant
mais non non c'était ma première idée
c'est terminé
c'est une blague c'était sur dix est
rien on était en train de revenir le
magasin était derrière
j'ai regardé ont l'air tellement gentil
juin je pas les emmerder par contre on
était beaucoup me retrouve pas dans
notre analyse le dernier on se planque
par ce jeu et autant génial qui fout la
haine et à rien les gars de party poker
et vous cachez filet allait filer le
troisième manche et dernière à l'écouter
on n'a pas besoin de faire un dessin
c'est incroyable ce que spaf on est donc
en nourrisson nous sommes des jumeaux
des jumeaux ferment en fait c'est
beaucoup d'investissement donc si nous
trouvons en moins de deux minutes
vraiment norad somme on est en train
devant le petit appel oui allô nous
sommes cachés
nous sommes cachés quoi quoi nous nous
sommes cachés sommes cachés enfin cache
cache cache et jacquet en arrivant là on
arrive alors on veut bien jouer avec
vous à tout ça tûranor collet est-ce que
je suis crédible si je fais non à la
'journée mars
pour moi ils sont sous des feuilles ou
dans une guinée ou un truc comme ça ils
peuvent pas être ailleurs sur ok on voit
là que c'est bon c'est pile entre là on
est et le lac kononova go max à l'actif
toi ils sont là bas c'est sûr faire pour
moi ils sont verts c'est obligé
- ils sont là se trouve la statue c'est
carlito déguisées ça se trouve ils sont
dans la plus apte
j'y ai pensé mais je dis que la mer
jeudi les pierres et des depuis tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
pardon pardon je te suis ces vaccins
mais justement il ya des traces
il ya des traces qu'on va les trouver je
reconnais les traces de semaine de raf
n'y a qu'une paire de traces il n'y a
rien à droite là où c'est plus sur le
chemin on sait d'où elle vient vers des
infirmières aller vite vite vite grâce
ya pas une grotte la barre c'est
interdit sa route à tout j'ai vu des
pieds dépasser les 17 kg et rigoureux
dans le jeu ne serait ce qu'au cas où
vous venez faisait bizarre je sais pas
et le fait qu'il avait cette colle et
minimath au hockey en france en raison
des attentats évités mais parce que le
feu doux
merci sens là et cela on peut voir mon
bébé pour le bébé
laissez les tranquilles si papa je suis
très tranquille
les banques versaient s'est confondue
cache-cache deux sont des zombies masse
et les biens publics
va t on si je ne viens pas classique
ça devient vraiment très agressif c'est
cool
j'ai trouvé une photo a les photos c'est
évidemment de dépasser ces veillées
musée moi vous n'êtes pas bougé passé la
photo j'ai vu les voies les chaussures
des passes à neauphle à deux dos mais
toi tu est incroyable et été incroyable
bien joué waouh quel magnifique aventure
humaine la cachette est légendaire et
nos folles québec les mecs
cette cachette était probalement l'une
des plus fortes et amusante de tout
combat ces deux comédiens parisiens
plus le temps passe mais pour l'instant
vous conduisez vous nous trouvez là
ex-aequo si vous ne trouvez pas on a
gagné
les bb brunes petit bébé bonne chance à
l'essai pour chaque vidéo où ils
souffrent les amis pour cette troisième
et dernière cachette on a mis le paquet
pour qu'on a eu cette idée je sais pas
soit descendre avec une corde on aura
notre ustensiles pour la bd vite on va
vraiment laver des vitres avec un binôme
qui va nous accompagner à quand le seul
bémol c'est que personne dans la rue du
coup j'espère qu'ils vont pas avoir
dirai qui tu es de regarder en l'air le
fait qu'on soit 4 c'est cool parce que
ça va un peu [ __ ] à faire avec
j'ai peur du vide c'est quoi mais vu que
disons-le and put alors je pense qu'il a
il semble qu'on ait grillé un bébé ils
ont une haine incroyable alors on va
s'équiper
c'est parti ok les gars je vous fais sur
un truc c'est en bas ils nous appellent
et qui font rêver au nous on va faire ça
vous voulez regarder vraiment ok les
mecs on a gâché vous prévenir
[Musique]
au bond maxence a eu un courage hors
norme
moi j'ai fait la décalade au canada on
se souvient mais j'me chie quand même
dessus très fort c'est sûr ils sont
allés pousser un truc loin fort ouais ok
[Musique]
3-2 agovv sa poubelle attendant une
allure des bouteilles non mais non
impossible depuis en très naturellement
mon jeu et mon père est un café il
récompense était un café
des choses pas possible ils sont si
forts que ça oh là là quoi non je
faisais c'était un faux mur [ __ ]
monjack fait baiser lee personnes poster
chigot levada c'est magnifique j'ai
envie de rentrer à la base mais non on
assume des ghana pense qu'ils se
retournent
là il se retourne pas ce qu'ils sont en
train de laver un hôpital philippe
séguin à gauche la savoie et qui à
gauche il s'appelait comment peut voir
le visage de pierre steulet je te donne
sept numéros déjà montré son visage
c'est pas lui c'est vrai non mais ça
veut dire qu'ils sont à l'endroit le
plus simple tu vois les buissons ils
l'ont fait en cuisson mais si je suis
sur les monts ce [ __ ] ses démons ses
laves rien du tout mais qui sait des
particuliers personnes là venez vite de
particuliers non on a gagné on a gagné
mais la vache mais même des malades qui
a eu cette idée de versailles bravo que
cette idée est géniale
oh là là elle est magnifique le tournage
de malades
forcément vous ayez ans vous aviez
envisagé mais super mec qui entend sa
chambre parce que si des lettres comme
toi donc trois partout au pays et
gagnent été parfait la leaf est parti
car vous allez trouver des cachettes
incroyable 5 mio chf ou merci au nord
d'abord si pour vous la vidéo d'art
permis de faire des gâchettes mais
aujourd'hui aussi violent jean aller
aussi loin dans le cache cache les amis
on n'est ce pas ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si vous
voulez un deuxième épisode bien sûr tel
dans un autre pays à bientôt de la
prochaine vidéo au revoir au revoir
[Musique]